good morning Hank it's Monday using the
magical power of green screens I have
transported myself to your home office
in Missoula Montana to show you
something that has been annoying the
crap out of me let's go to the tape
you're making a nice video bug it's
funny everybody's laughing there there
enhance there that thing oh so annoying
I think it's GLaDOS she has to go she's
annoying me if only this weren't a green
screen oh wait it's not goodbye Oh The
Illustrated guide to free hugs just
broke everything is fine nothing is
broken book a tank you change the poster
oh sorry I can fix that I am doing this
is I mean excessive it's a bit obnoxious
too forward I don't know what happens if
you go to that link so I pull all the
way to Montana so I could be in a hank
games video Hank and John play fifa 11
poorly very bad man oh and you get to
the penalty kicks that's the second
episode yeah stay tuned for tomorrow
when you will see us miss 19 consecutive
penalties but we played perhaps the
worst match that Liverpool and Arsenal
have ever played yes a hold on a second
a home flash a kick you should make that
a clickable link there is also a link in
the doobly-doo and also in the future
I'm gonna be making more Hank games
videos with Hank which I'm really
excited about because I'm really bad at
video games but I'm really passionate
about them that's the same way I felt
about skateboarding when I was 10
another thing I have a punishment and I
can't do the sandwich punishment because
do you want to show them your scars not
really okay you just have to trust me
that I was lately removed from my
gallbladder really your gallbladder got
the worst part of that deal that's true
I wrote a haiku for the occasion
actually would you like to hear it
please
stupid gallbladder not performing
properly I will kill you now
yeah so my gallbladder was taken out
which means I can't really do the
sandwich punishment so if you could
suggest a different
for me I would appreciate it and Hank
will pick one in other news we do have a
punishment for Hank so in addition to
bringing myself in my family to Montana
I also brought one box full of sheets
from The Fault in Our Stars this is 7400
sheets and that is 5% of the total and
I'm going to Hank ler fish all of them
good fish I'm going to hang on fish then
I'm going to ride an angler fish on each
one of those pieces they believe you'll
have a 5% chance of getting a hanger
fished Fault in Our Stars I made up a
word and I verb date verb so a hank or
fish is a is it angler fish drawn by 1/2
uh-huh there are other Hanks that can
make angler fish so like if Hank
Williams the third were to draw me an
angler fish that would be a heaven also
be an angler fish it would probably be
better than mine too so I had to bring
all these copies of The Fault in Our
Stars because I can't take a week off
from signing right he has to sign them
anyways he had to bring them to sign me
yeah just in case you don't know by the
way everybody who pre-orders The Fault
in Our Stars will get a sign
hold on a second all 300 copies will be
signed and 5% will be Hank lore fish all
right we've got to go to breakfast
nerdfighters don't forget to be awesome
best wishes don't talk about my shirt or
I'll put Forks in you what's that from
it's really old vlogger this video I
mean I taught an evening master God made
this we have so many inside jokes that I
don't even get pen along spin along
don't talk to me about my t-shirt or I
will put Forks in you that's a great
t-shirt actually I know we should think
that should be a thing well I think I'm
like me having the only one all right
goodbye goodbye Hank I'll see you when I
turn off the camera okay